[Music]
[Music]
we couldn't imagine anyone else trying
to fill Carlos de Vil's leather boots
Cameron Boyce did his character justice
and helped turn the descendents
franchise into the Empire it is today
without Carlos the BK's would never have
stuck together or defeated their enemies
here's why Carlos de Vil is the hero of
The Descendants franchise my printer my
crime
yeah about that I before we get into why
Carlos is a total hero we thought it'd
be appropriate to revisit his childhood
after all it's here that we find out
that despite is surroundings Carlos has
a heart of gold in Isle of the Lost a
descendents novel were introduced to a
paranoid and jumpy Carlos his mother
Cruella treats him badly forcing him to
sleep on the floor in her dressing room
which is aligned with fair traps thanks
to his mother Carlos is terrified of
dogs and she uses this to control him
mom said they're rabid pack animals who
eat boys before the events of
descendants takes place mal is a big bad
bully who forces Carlos to host her
birthday party during this time mal
locks Evie inside of Cruella's dressing
room and Carlos saves her from the bear
traps
despite being raised to do bad carlos
follows his big golden heart and does
the right thing and as a result of his
kindness Evie and Carlos formed their
very first friendship on top of having a
big heart Carlos is also a natural
leader for the longest time Cruella
claimed that Carlos was a follower but
her only child knew better and longed to
prove her wrong we don't have to be
worried about how really matter
Carlos proved that he could stand up for
himself and make his own decisions when
he chose to be good at the end of the
first Descendants film his leadership
skills led to him becoming somewhat of a
hero on the Isle of the Lost
after all Carlos went from being the
runt of the Isle to a leader in a few
short months another reason why Carlos
is such an important addition to the
descendents franchise has everything to
do with his character whereas mal Jay
and Evie would rather sweep things under
the rug Carlos wants to talk things out
as a group if it weren't for Carlos the
rest of the V case might have lost touch
during their time in auradon
however Carlos kept the group alive by
being honest about his feelings and
talking to his friends about their own
at the end of descendants to Carlos
realized that mal wasn't doing too good
so instead of turning away in good BK
fashion
Carlos chose to have a heart-to-heart
with his besties being a part of Malan
V's Girl Talk sort of made him
uncomfortable but if
through it after abandoning his mother
and his roots Carlos chose to view his
fellow BK's as his family and he wanted
to support them no matter what
Maui BJ and Carlos each bring something
to the table mal is powerful and
intuitive Evie is fashionable and
upfront Jay is strong and loyal and
Carlos is the brains of the operation
ceviches wouldn't have gotten far
without Carlos's help in the first
Descendants film Carlos leads the vks to
the museum 2.3 miles from here and helps
them in their attempt to steal the fairy
godmothers wand when Jay tripped the
alarm
Carlos uses that big brain of his to
convince the alarm system operator that
the alarm sounded due to a system error
if it hadn't been for Carlos the BK's
would have been busted and sent back to
the Isle of the lost in record speed
Carlos proves just how valuable he is
once again in descendants - when he
literally saves all of word on from
human or crew of pirates Carlos is a
whiz when it comes to technology which
is why he creates the most high-tech 3d
printer in all of auradon when mal runs
away and the BK's go to the isle to
bring her back King then gets kidnapped
by uma and her crew Lula is willing to
trade Ben for the fairy godmothers wand
thanks to Carlos the BK's are able to 3d
print a fake wand and treat it for Ben's
so Carlos's heroism doesn't stop there
on top of being sweet brave and giving
Carlos is also open minded he faces his
fears and befriends dude the dog forming
an unbreakable bond
his lover dude helps him realize that
his mother tricked him into submission
which leads to him finally speaking up
for himself but if that wasn't enough
Carlos is the furthest thing from
superficial despite Janne thinking she's
ugly Carlos falls in love with her he
thinks she's beautiful and loves her
personality if it hadn't been for
Carlos's crush on Jean mal would have
never been able to convince
that the 3d printed wand was the real
deal now used the fact that dude the dog
could talk to convinced uma that the
wand was legit but if it hadn't been for
Carlos's crush on gene dude the dog
would have never eaten a truth gummy and
learned how to speak you just gotta man
up and while you're at it
scratch my pot so in the end Carlos's
big brain and big heart are what truly
saved the day in descendants - sure mal
turning into a dragon stop Duma from
getting her revenge but Carlos helped
the gang bring King's Own back to Oregon
safe and sound although Carlos might not
be the most obvious hero he sees the day
more than once despite being a little
nervous when it comes to breaking rules
Carlos is super loyal and would follow
his friends to the ends of the earth
who's your favorite BK tell us in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
if you think Carlos Scoville is the
sweetest BK in auradon for more videos
about the cast of descendants hit that
subscribe button thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]